in this video I'm going to talk about
cell cycle control by TGF beta signaling
so TGF beta signaling is very important
for cell cycle control and this TGF beta
signaling starts with the liand the
transforming growth factor beta and this
ligan bind to the two type of receptor
type one receptor and type two receptors
so basically upon ligan binding so there
is a heterodimerization of this receptor
and this heterodimerization event is
very important for uh the initiation of
these TGF beta mediated signals so once
the Lan bind to this one receptor other
receptor comes in and dimerize from this
type of TGF beta heterodimer and this
heterodimer receptors get phosphorilated
upon Lian Mining and this phosphor
phosphorilated uh Lian phosphorilated
receptor cytoplasmic tail helps the
arsad so the these mad molecules these
are very important for these TGF beta
signaling pathway and these rmad
molecules that means receptor mediated
mad molecules get
phosphorilated now this ARS mad bound
with its partner
kmad uh entirely migrate to the nucleus
and where it will attach with a DNA
binding partner and sit up on the gene
on a Target Gene the promoter of a
Target Gene and it will transcribe the
target Gene and this target Gene MRNA
would be produced and thus the protein
would be produced so what are the Target
genes for these TGF beta signaling
pathway so basically as I have told that
TGF beta signaling is a basically
inhibitory signaling pathway for cell
cycle control so basically TGF beta will
Target the genes that will produce ckis
that means cyc cyc independent KY is
Inhibitors so basically tgfb signaling
will ultimately give rise to higher
level of cyclindependent kyes Inhibitors
and cyclindependent kyes inhibitors for
instance here I have shown that p50 p15
which is a inhibitor of cyclan D cdk4
complex so it what it will do uh it will
inhibit cyclan D and cdk4 and thus
inhibiting the cell cycle progression
and further growth so this is how TGF
bet signaling works so experimental
evidences show that when TGF beta is
applied to the human cultured keratos
sites uh one saw that a 30-fold increase
in p15 mRNA expression level so that
suggest that huge amount of ckis are
produced uh when TGF betas are applied
and thus the cell cycle growth is
checked and cell cycle progression is
checked and also induction in the p15
level is observed so here are some list
of uh ckis that are uh inhibiting cyclan
D and cdk4 complex basically uh cycling
basically
P5 p16 p18 and p19 these cycl dependent
kyes Inhibitors inhibit cyclan D cdk4
complexes others like p27 p21 and
P57 inhibits other uh cyclan cdk
complexes such asy clean e and cdk1
complexes so this is very important in
the cell cycle control because uh the
growth or cell division cannot uh last
for whole time so it have to be
regulated it have to be checked and this
TGF beta signaling pathway basically
puts a trigger for uh cell cycle growth
and uh SEL cycle growth
and the abnormal cell growth and
abnormal cell division uh that's all
please like And subscribe thank you